but I don't want to take I don't want to
put you in that spot I love this guy
right here let me give this guy I love
this guy right here yeah and that's from
the heart I didn't want to put you in
that position
yeah that's from the heart special guy
special guy
special moment Kanye West hugged it out
with President Donald Trump during his
much-hyped visit to the Oval Office on
Thursday and yes he was sporting a make
America great again hat this hat
it gives me it gives me power away there
was something about when I put this hat
off and made me feel like Superman
you made a Superman now that's my
favorite superhero and you made a
Superman cape for me also as a guy that
looks up to you looks up to wrap around
list up to American industry guys
non-political no bull it put the beef on
it how do you want to do it five seconds
to lay it just goes in and gets it done
the visit comes about two weeks after
the outspoken rapper went on a
controversial rant following a
performance on SNL so many times I
talked to a white person about how these
races well if I was wrong about race in
the moment
what I need Saturday Night Live's have
proved on or unnies the Liberals to
improve on it if he don't look good we
don't look good this is our president he
has to be the freshest the bias the
flyest plays the best factory and we
have to make our core be in power we
have to bring jobs into America because
our best exports is entertainment ideas
but when we make everything in China and
not in America then we're cheating on
our country and we're putting people in
positions that have to do illegal things
to end up in a cheapest Factory ever the
prison system Kanye's wife Kim
Kardashian has had her own meetings with
Trump about reforming the prison system
Alice she famously helped to free a
woman named Alice Marie Johnson earlier
this year the only person that can grant
her clemency would be the president
you're out
still Kim and Kanye are on opposite ends
of the political spectrum just because
he has an opinion
it doesn't mean mentally ill but a
source tells et that works for them whoa
- Kim and Kanye are both passionate
people who stand up for what they
believe in and understand when they
don't agree on something that it's
healthy and makes their relationship
stronger you know I've seen him go
through a lot
most genuine person and you know he
might say things that might get
misinterpreted and people don't see the
context behind it but I always know his
heart